hello my beautiful children get ready to
put on your stilettos and burn some sage
[ __ ] because it's episode six of
american horror story apocalypse
and this one's a real tearjerker after i
died of laughter for the first two
minutes of this episode mr and mrs james
aka madison and behold sign the deed to
murder house
madison has been instructed by cordelia
to search langdon's childhood home for
clues about michael's past
if they're going to show michael as pure
evil they'll need proof
the real estate agent tells them he's
legally obligated to tell them about the
deaths that have happened on the
property
all 36 of them but seeing as behold and
madison are badass magic users they
decide to purchase it anyway
even though madison refers to it as a
[ __ ] then again she's always a diva
and behold isn't afraid to call her out
on it behold tries to use magic on the
front door but it doesn't work the
powers of the witches and warlocks here
are thrown off kilter
behold telling madison that the psychic
energy here is stronger than he's ever
felt before it's not a home but a prison
a prison for the murdered victims behold
even saying i pity the souls trapped
here
it must be hell and if you've seen
season one we know that for the ghosts
that roam murder house it
is their own hell they're trapped there
for good later on when the satanists
arrive we'll learn that the house itself
was built on a portal to hell
behold takes out his warlock supplies to
prepare for a ritual
michael's family died in this home and
they need those spirits to show
themselves so they can find out more
about him
he reads from a spell book saying
monstra to spiritum
nu abscondes which is latin for show
your spirits
do not hide we get a brief glimpse of
one of the nurses who died in murder
house season 1
the smoldering children and backed by
popular demand
it's tate who's in the middle of ghost
therapy with dr ben
harmon tate is dealing with normal ghost
problems he's being ignored by the love
of his life violet
or love of his death if we want to get
literal because she found out he shot up
a school
and impregnated her mother she's violet
he's a changed man get over it
madison and behold interrupt the session
they seem to know all about ben and tate
behold even brings up that ben's wife
vivian died giving birth to michael
he's the child of a human vivien and
spirit
tate if you remember from season one
billy dean howard medium to the stars
predicted the very nature of the
antichrist
a child born of human and spirit
will usher in the end of times
it is the essence of evil tate warns
them that
even people protected from magic aren't
safe in this house
but madison and behold aren't going to
leave empty-handed they promise to get
out of the spirit's hair as long as they
answer some questions
but the house has a few tricks up its
sleeve as a creepy red ball
drops from the stairs madison is tackled
by bow constant langdon's handsome son
she kept locked in the attic he shoot
off madison by none other than billy
dean who we learn is alive being allowed
to walk freely in and out of the house
unharmed by the spirits and then we get
one of the most
epic moments so far this season the
return of constance langdon who says
and this is my [ __ ] house
madison behold make their intentions
known to constance who doesn't seem
too pleased they're there they're
interrupted by moira o'hara yet another
character from season 1 who had sex with
constance's husband
and was subsequently killed for it and
judging by constance's back and forth
with her she's still not over it
madison behold questioned constance and
billy about michael
she doesn't give away info for free if
they can abracadabra that [ __ ] moira
out of the house
constance will tell them everything they
need to know so they do the only logical
thing and dig up her body in the
backyard
they uncover a skull but it's not
moira's that was likely the skull of
hayden maclaine the lover of ben harmon
who is also buried there back in season
1.
they uncover her bones in what has to be
the weirdest gift
ever burying her back with her mother
who she killed back in season one
notice the date of death 2011 the year
murder house takes place
moira is given a wonderful send-off with
her mother so she can be smothered with
kisses for eternity
madison behold victorious in getting
moira out of the house meet with
consonants in the hopes she keeps up her
end of the bargain constance tells them
everything she knows how she assumed the
burden of taking care of michael after
his mother died during birth
michael was to be her second chance of
raising a good boy after everything that
happened with
tate she kept baby michael in the mirror
room the same room she used to punish
her daughter addie when she was being
naughty as he grew up he would kill
small rodents and leave them as presents
for her mother and these gifts just keep
getting better
she realizes that god put her on earth
to raise these monsters and it gave her
a sense of purpose
after michael would kill she would plant
a small rose bush as a burial spot until
her entire backyard was filled with
bushes
his first human kill happened at the age
of three his babysitter who constance
was able to pass off as a suicide but
even stranger was the fact he aged over
a decade in one night
as if he was in a hurry to get somewhere
age-wise
he then attempts to kill grandma almost
as if something has taken over him
he snaps out of it and the two share a
heartwarming grandmother grandson moment
with him aging and his sporadic bouts of
choking she would need
sacred intervention and we all know how
that turned out constance tells them
that michael made her feel like her life
mattered but that slowly died away
knowing at any moment he could slit her
throat she was nothing but an invisible
stepping stone to where he was going
distraught and feeling betrayed by god
she ventures into the murder house and
commit suicide
od on pills and alcohol she never wanted
to see michael again
upon her awakening she finds three of
her children waiting for her
addie noticeably absent because if you
remember from season one she did not die
in the house rather was brutally run
over by a car on halloween
after she tells her story she's
interrupted by her daughter who
inexplicably has no eyes before fading
away
and thank god there was a commercial
break after this scene because we then
see ben harmon tearjerking it in what
has to be the saddest happy ending ever
madison behold promise him if he tells
them what he knows about michael they
can fix his
crying problems michael uncovers his
grandmother's body and ben
tells him her grandmother doesn't want
to see him the spirits in this house can
only be seen when they want to be seen
ben wants to help him he can't help but
think of him as his own son
even though biologically he isn't in a
sweet little montage
they do fun things like play catch and
make crosses on rubik's cubes when
michael meets his real dad
stay away from my [ __ ] you understand
it's heartwarming to say the least
papa tate makes tater tot cry saying not
even himself could make something as
monstrous as michael michael turns away
from good and embraces the dark side
performing gruesome
surgeries in the basement when the house
sells he kills the new owners showing no
remorse but even more stunning is his
ability to destroy their souls
in a display of his new power one he
doesn't realize he has himself
he lights the two souls on fire making
them cease to exist
ben then turns on him telling him he
could have never helped michael
and now michael has lost the only two
figures who have loved him in life
this betrayal by the ones who loved him
most is likely the catalyst for him
going full
evil madison says they need to go back
to cordelia and tell her what they know
their new supreme is pure
evil but they're interrupted by vivian
michael's biological mother and ben goes
to take care of the crying baby if you
remember from season one
vivian gives birth to two children one
of whom died during the birth
the other being michael she warns
madison and behold quoting a passage
from revelations chapter 13
referring to the antichrist then i saw a
beast with ten
horns and seven heads rising out of the
sea and all who dwell on the earth will
worship him
vivian describes her experience with
michael how crows would circle the house
how
hot it was inside in the arrival of the
black pope
anton levay and his cardinals one of
them being mead
the other played by the actress who
played pepper anton tells him it's time
to remove the scales from his eyes
in the book of revelations there are a
number of references to a dragon
vivian tells them at first she didn't
take the satanist seriously they were
lost souls following a con man from some
circus a nod to freak show everything
seemed fine
until the black mass mead pulls up and
offers a ride to a young girl as don't
fear the reaper plays on the radio the
girl says thanks you're a lifesaver but
we know her life will be far from saved
notice the upside down cross hanging
from the rear view mirror
and the syringe mead stabs the girl with
it's such a lovely night for murder
isn't it the black mass begins with
anton copping a feel and passing a
dagger to one of the cardinals
she tells michael it's all for you
a nod to 1976's the omen
in a scene from temple of doom anton
pulls out the young girl's heart and
it's given to michael to eat
yum and we watch as the shadow of the
devil looms over him
the other satanists bowing in reverence
vivian
fearing what michael has become makes
the decision to kill him as she does she
notices
666 the number of the beasts that was
described in the bible passage vivian
mentioned earlier from revelations her
attempt to kill michael fails as he
engulfs her in flames only for her to be
saved by tate
from that day forward he was gone vivian
says neither ben nor tate were the
father rather he was born from the evil
of the house
the source of darkness is his true
father and he has come to destroy the
world
bringing billie jean's prophecy to
fruition madison and behold prepare to
leave behold telling her that if he had
known michael was this evil they would
never have made him supreme he asked her
what they would do if they can't stop
him a question madison doesn't have the
answer to
violet explains to madison her troubles
with tate and in a real turn for
madison's character
she consoles her telling her that the
real evil isn't tate
rather the house it used him as a vessel
to commit those evil deeds
she thinks that the evil inside tate
left with michael giving violet hope of
a future relationship with her sexy
ghost boy
madison blows some fairy dust so she can
look fabulous and she now magically
knows how tate saved his mom
they embrace as the police spirits of
the material world plays in the
background
madison and behold driving back to
cordelia this episode focused primarily
on backstory in fact it really didn't
advance the plot at all but i was okay
with that since we learned more about
who michael
is and how he became that way his
upbringing was one of tragedy his mother
dying in childbirth and the two people
who cared for him the most turning their
backs on him
it's no wonder when the satanist arrived
telling him he was special that he
turned to them
and embraced his true path but this
episode was a total nostalgia trip for
fans of season 1
getting to reunite with old characters
giving a proper send-off to moira and
constance and finally answering what
made tate so evil
what i'm interested in is how the
witches will use this new information to
gain the upper hand on michael who will
they need to seek out in order to put a
stop to michael for good
we know it won't go over well because
the apocalypse does eventually happen
but with the witches thankfully
surviving
i think the key to all this resides with
mallory in the last episode we saw her
heal
a deer but not only did she heal it it
regained its youth becoming a doe
if michael can banish souls for good can
malory bring them back
is she the key to somehow reverting the
apocalypse
and what will ariel do when he finds out
about michael's true past
remember me told michael not to bring up
who his father was to him and ariel only
wanted michael to be alpha so he could
stick it to the witches
not to mention we still don't know
what's going to happen in the current
timeline cordelia raised cocodina and
mallory from the dead before they were
interrupted by michael
what will he do to them or rather what
will they do to him that's it for this
breakdown
if you liked this video make sure to
give it a like and if you didn't meet me
out back by the gazebo
i also have a new twitter where you can
get updates on my latest videos or if
you just want to troll me and last but
not least because i was a bad boy and
didn't do it last week
i want you all to remember daddy loves
you very much